c'est fanny j beau bonjour merci d'être
avec nous alors peut-être tout d'abord
évoqué l'état de santé un julian assange
au mois de novembre déjà des médecins
dans une lettre ouverte s'inquiéter pour
lui en savez vous plus écoutez moi à
titre personnel je ne fait qu'écouter
les médias et suivre ce qui se passe
bien évidemment on ne peut tous
comprendre que ça que sa santé soit soit
en danger et vous imaginez il a passé
sept années dans dans l'ambassade
équateur à londres dans une petite pièce
et puis il est enfermé dans cette prison
de haute sécurité depuis un an et demi
maintenant
comment voulez vous qu'il en soit
autrement alors le cas julien assange et
ses avocats rappellent que ça un travail
journalistique qu'il a fait de l'autre
côté on leur reproche justement d'avoir
dépassé son travail de journaliste et de
cette rendus coupables d'espionnage
on en revient donc au journalisme
d'investigation est il assez encadrée en
france et ailleurs dans le monde
et vous voyez bien que la problématique
c'est justement uniquement un problème
politique puisqu'on parle de liberté
d'expression on parle de liberté de la
presse donc depuis l'enfermement de
tulle menaçante on en est à 8 ans 8 ans
et demi maintenant tous les journalistes
de par la planète toutes les
associations de défense de journalistes
auraient dû être auprès de lui pour
justement le soutenir alors on voit
depuis quelques temps qu effectivement
certaines voix commencent à se lever et
heureusement mais au delà de la liberté
d'expression et au delà de la liberté de
la presse
il me semble moins en tant que lanceur d
alerte que ce dossier est
essentiellement un dossier politique et
pourquoi vous avez parlé dans votre
reportage de monsieur dupont moretti qui
avaient des oreilles en 2017 que les
lanceurs d'alertés tu es des délateurs
il est ensuite devenu l'avocat de thunes
assange en disant écoutez la france doit
doivent doit proposer l'asile
maintenant qu'il est ministre de la
justice on voit finalement que le départ
de madame bilger juge d'instruction qui
travaille sur le dossier de monsieur
bayrou sur d'espoir de détournement de
fonds publics est bien plus rapide que
son
que ça que sa précipitation pour aller
voir le président emmanuel macron et
demander l'asile
alors l'asile politique déjà été
demandée depuis 2013 donc la france si
vous voulez et ridiculiser avec la
liberté d'expression avec la liberté de
la presse en refusant le l'asile de dieu
que nation qui avait d'ailleurs été
aussi refusé pour éloigner d'un deuil et
pourquoi la france est ridiculisée
aujourd'hui parce qu'un tribunal
américain vient de juger illicites les
écoutes de la haine et c'est donc avait
été révélé par les protestants d'heure
est reprise par wikileaks ces écoutes
étaient et les sites pour les citoyens
américains mais aussi pour les citoyens
étrangers et donc les présidents et les
démocraties étrangères qui avaient été
écoutés on entre donc la dent du droit
international et chez nous en france au
niveau du droit pénal
alors il ya quand même les intérêts de
la nation qui sont mises en danger et on
a quoi de quoi s'interroger sur cet
aspect de soumission par rapport à une
puissance étrangère
alors cela étant dit on dit souvent mais
du loup menaçant jeu finalement c'était
secret d'étain qui l'a milliers comme
sain sur la place publique
c'est en gros pour ça il mérite cette
situation les faut arrêter avec ce type
de discours ce ne sont pas des secrets
d'état qui ont été révélés ce sont des
crimes d'état qui montre qu'il ya un
autre soin de ce qu'on peut appeler nos
élites politiques complices à
l'international qui ont usurpé tous les
efforts des lanceurs dallaire tous les
sacrifices qu'ont fait les lanceurs
dallaire depuis toutes ces dernières
années puisque nous lanceurs d'alertés
par l'odeur l'instant peut parler aussi
de chelsea manning et tant d'autres qui
se sont levés sont tous des résistants
combattants pour la liberté et la france
est le pays de la liberté alors le titre
de votre ouvrage 1 est lourd de sens un
la traque des lanceurs d'alert selon
vous dans quel monde bascule ton quand
on dénonce alors moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on
moi personnellement je suis dans cette
histoire en france contre la banque
quand la banque ubs c'est histoire
d'évasion fiscale mais aussi à être
reconnu par l'état français qui m'a fait
sortir ses informations confidentielles
qui appartenait le serveur de mon
employeur et qui quelque part mine mais
mise en danger
donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui la
traque va s'inverser
nous avons été traqués comme des animaux
depuis plus de 10 ans dans un silence de
cathédrale politiques de gauche de
droite
tout ça c'est un peu la même chose on
fait des grands mots en disant qu'on va
protéger les gens et finalement on se
rend compte que les informations sont
toujours bien mieux protégés que les
citoyens aujourd'hui ça va s'inverser et
pourquoi parce qu'on arrive à un
bouleversement le 12 septembre notamment
qu' être rassemblement dédié les jaunes
va permettre parce que certains d'entre
eux comme vous le savez et soutiennent
julian assange et soutiennent les
lanceurs d'alert vont être rejoints ccg
des jaunes qui milite pour la liberté
d'expression et puis pour l'asile
d'assange en france ils vont être
rejoints par tous les
parents des collégiens des lycéens à qui
on impose des masques et qui commence à
souffrir à l'école où cette douleur des
enfants qui commencent à avoir des
saignements qui commence à avoir des
maux de tête est absolument
insupportable face à un mensonge d'état
face à des gens qui sur des plateaux de
télé sont là en permanence en train de
donner des leçons de morale alors qu'ils
reçoivent des commissions est souvent
une commission sur des comptes off shore
pour aller faire la publicité de
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
donc tout ça ça suffit hier j'ai eu un
policier au téléphone qui me disait que
les gardes du corps de nos dirigeants
politiques de nos élites politiques vont
finalement comprendre et se réveiller en
disant qu'il va pas leur mieux défendre
leurs propres enfants qu'elle allait
défendre des élites corrompues
donc on se sent moins qu'on arrive à un
basculement et qu'il va arriver très
bientôt ce sont certainement les gilet
jaune qui vont porter la voix de ce
qu'est la france et l'international des
valeurs qu'elles représentent ainsi que
de tous les lanceurs d'alerté qui sont
sacrifiés sur 7 sur 7 au tél
du mensonge en bande organisée savané
gibault merci d'avoir été en direct avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes auteur de
l ouvrage
la traque des lanceurs d'alert préfacé
par julian assange merci merci